cher journal je me demande pourquoi les
gens qui disent je dis ça je dis rien
10,1 plutôt que de ne dira rien
c'est comme ceux qui disent parlons peu
parlons bien alors qu'il ne parle ni
peut ni bien vanessa ah tu dit tout et
son contraire
c'est pourquoi as tu eu si peur de terre
non non ne me dis pas écoute écoute le
silence écoute ton coeur crier dans ta
poitrine
il n'y a que toi qui peux l'entendre et
soyons honnêtes c'est mieux comme ça
pourquoi tu dis un petit café quand tu
commandes en allonger pourquoi tu
répondants s'inquiètent alors que
personne ne s'inquiète
pourquoi tu commandes tout en disant no
comments pourquoi quand on te demande si
ça va tu réponds un oui sec pour bien
montrer que ça va pas pourquoi tu
ponctuent toutes tes phrases paroupians
29,1 on ne s'entend même plus qu écrire
avec toi j'ai appris un truc de ouf
non je peux absolument pas de parler à
temps je suis neuf de confiance moi pas
tu dis bref sans être bref tu dis là lol
dans la vraie vie alors que tu ne
souffre que d'une et quand tu l'écris
pourquoi rebord tu fièrement ce
mystérieux tatouage sur son avant-bras
s'il est trop personnelle car que tu
dévoiles sa signification maintenant tu
sais moi j'ai arrêté des soldats moi
j'ai un tatouage dont je ne veux pas
parler mais il a un endroit dont je ne
peux pas parler auquel personne ou
presque n'a accès et devine quoi vanessa
et ben personne n'en parle
alors je vais faire une confidence sur
un journal parce que je sais que tu le
gardera pour toi ce qui est mineur chez
les autres c'est surtout ce qui m'énerve
chez moi vous rendrez [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Musique]
choules est gentil mais c'est ouf
les gens sont nerveux chez